The last thing I want to tell you before we go into programming
is why this makes any sense.
Suppose you fill the matrix, which I call omega [Ω],
and the vector, which I give the Greek name of xi [ξ].
My apologies to my non-Greek students here.
You Greek students should be very proud.
You'll always have a special place in my mathematical heart.
Then I can find the best solution for all the landmark positions or the world positions
by a very simple mathematical trick that is completely counterintuitive.
I invert the omega, I right multiply with xi, and out comes a vector mu [µ],
which gives me the best estimates for all the robot locations and the landmark locations.
Now, that is quite amazing, because all it means in Graph SLAM is
that you keep adding numbers to these matrices every time you see a constraint.
When you're done with it, you run a very simple procedure
and out comes the best places for your robot.
Let's go and try it. I'm now going to ask you to program this.
I'm giving you my matrix class, so you can do this easily.
What I'm asking you to do is to build a 3 x 3 matrix and, of course, a 3 x 1 vector
about which you shall state that our initial location is -3.
X1 in exportation is obtained by adding 5 to x0 and x2 is obtained by adding 3 to x1.
In exportation what we should get out when we run
the mu equals omega minus 1 times xi trick is that x0 becomes -3,
x1 becomes 2, and x2 becomes 5.
Diving straight into our programming environment,
I'm giving you a matrix class--you might want to take a moment to look over it.
It's a little bit augmented to what I've given you before,
and I fixed a bug with the inversion code, which is quite essential.
If I run it, I construct an omega matrix piece-by-piece--
that's the one that you should come out with--
a xi vector, and then I run and print out, using the "show" command,
the result of omega to the -1 times c.
You can see -3, 2, and 5 are the correct results
that result from the omega matrix and the xi vector.
What I want you to do is write code that incrementally step-by-step constructs
the omega vector and the xi function and then returns to me those results over here.
There is an empty function in your code that accepts as parameter
the initial position, -3, and the two motion values, 5 and 3.